こんにちははじめしたそうですあ
ワクチン2回目
ウッチ終わりました
モデルな服反動が相当きつかったんです
けど打ち乗り越えて東京でずっとあの療養
というかおとなしくしてたんですけども
声ます今ですね東京の家にいるんですけど
も名バック光院入学こういったがすごい
[音楽]
てくれました
簡単に言うとです
名瀑行為方されてるんですよ
となりかなちょっとわからないんですけど
ただひとつだけ言いたい方がございまして
人じゃないんですよ
1づらいんですものね恋人ではないなぜ
ならもん
ベランダから聞こえてくるんですよずっと
紺子キムチ近寄ってみます
[音楽]
結構ねあの想像を絶しするうるささなん
ですよ
うわぁ
もうこれでさあしてください皆さん
あとそっとが見れるとバレてしまうつバレ
ないようにこの原図を伝えたいんです
やはり必要も結構本当にはけれども強いし
俺大丈夫これ
うーんこはえっこえー
こわいよーあのう
あのわかると思いますが
取です
ベランダミニバスもうね地獄どあけっぱ
大丈夫へ入ってきて俺も終わるんだけど
人生結構マジ恋んですけど
見えます俺1回も外でたことないのにこの
羽の量やばすぎでしょこれもいるんですよ
これね皆さんいるんですよ
トリガー
無事のベランダに個別にこのマンションの
作りが悪いとかじゃなくて家に来た鳥が
悪いだけなんですよただ想像以上に山来て
てこっちの方がやばいんだよなあ
てゲーム配信設備が完成しました骨の方に
見ます
うわぁはヤバすぎる箸でねこれ
author 災害レベル4金とか
めっちゃ国立医ちゃってるんですよなんか
[音楽]
俺これさっさとてるのリスクでねもう
ホントやだホントやな
まず眠りまずできちょいマジで競え
喘息の現場をやはり中継するのが私の仕事
うわぁ
混ぜてきしょいんだけどやばいっても mo
うぇいうぇい
andere ウェイ
ラーやべゲームでちゃったギロじゃないん
ですねまた困ってるんですよね普通やばい
でしょ今のみました皆さん市長の家で
ウンコしてはいけないんですよ皆さん
なおしたらいいでしょこれどうしたらいい
でしょ僕今までこんな高層マンションに
住んだことないんでトリガー巣をつくっ
たり別の方と6時やに共闘生活させられる
体験が今までなくてですねヤバくないすか
これ高いからなのかなと高層マンションに
住んでる方に気を引きたいんですけど
ホリガーもして勝手に住んだらどうすれば
いいですか結構今一番困っているというか
ベランダきたら的でも嫌なんですよあそこ
織江なくてこっちから出るとたぶんね氏が
見えるような気がしますちょっと外の景色
わからない感じで外でてみましょうか
はいえーこちらですねーの文化が横分かり
やすいスタジオとなっております空撮を
投票時に身に住まわれている鳥はこちら
からご覧になられる
現場の方に足を運ばせ頂きましたが
さっそく見てみましょう
これだけどマジヤバいんですよ
長いないなぁ
今日いない洲崎飛んで行ったんかなぁ
もう
ここで全然 by つの家なんすよ多分
me
これさぁタッチはルイスよワンちゃんの隣
の部屋がうるさいとベルタつもりですよ人
の家で脱糞されてますから夫俺さあどう
すればいいんだろう今日は今行った時にい
なかったんですけどもこの前なうるさくて
よるミニ
いらっしゃいまして本人がべちょ写真に
コストリアが納めさせていただきました
瞬間の盗撮という形になってしまったん
ですけども一応ここ私がの賃貸お金して
いるお家なので一応私のプライベートの
場所という意味合いも込めてですねあの
家庭だから撮らせていただきましたが
こちらこの方がですねあの勝手に私の家の
方に住まれていらっしゃるという現状で
ございます
誰だ誰がマジでお前はハンドガンバットだ
んか
ハトっぽいよね鳩ってつの高層べでどうぞ
高いところまで来て質問なんだなね
ちょっと何かおふざけ陳腐な道になって
ますけど結構腹たってましたよ実際
所すればいい勝手に鳥が一緒に住むみたい
なものを持って今までほんとなかったん
ですよ静岡のうちも全部低いし鳩ってパソ
の東京特有なんかなまじでやばいです本当
なんかコツコツコツコツ入ってるし見た
通りですねベランダも1円全部糞まみれで
こんなに歩けないし結構でと精神的に
きついと思ってて
ほらもう行きこなした今関根今言いました
よ今
帰ってきたぁー
ふざけんなー
数がパンガーこれ作動乗車てが普通にまず
管理会社に電話
知事ましてあるんですけども対象方わかん
ないんですけどもねなんかこの初体系席で
皆さんにもお伝えしたかったです東京に
住むと鳩が不法入居していきます
ああ今今聞こえましたよもう最悪最悪規模
一文一文遺墨結構トリイ好きな方なんです
けどもあんなにもう全面糞みたいなことさ
れるとマジで嫌な気持ちになりました
なんかそのとリースんドリアン打つあの
東京の家のあー消す了解ですがそのうちだ
とはなるってことですかねはい
失礼します
ナイスまだナイフバーの一応なんかも駆除
業者さんとか動いてるみたいで近いうちに
何でもしてもらうんですけどもあのほんと
こういう動画でいうことではないのは重々
分かっているんですか
鳥の皆さんその家に勝手に住むのは非常に
良くない行為ですそんな日からうるさいと
はそういう迷惑行為上のことだと思ってて
あの僕がですね汗水たらして稼いだお金で
住んでるんですよこのおうちにその大地の
一角を勝手に使って済んでい住んでる本人
にも迷惑をかける
ああ今行き超えました2件なぁ
人間じゃねえからつっていいこと悪いこと
なんで失礼だよ
わーけっこイラついてるんですよ
なにあのこの動画をその鳥類の皆さん見
てるか分からないんですけど
人間じゃないから犬とか猫とか鳥類だから
といってやっていくぶん悪いことあるので
勝手に人がお金を出して住んでいるお家
そういう場所に無断で澄香をつくったり
汚したりする行為はすべての走塁に
やめてほしいと言いたいこの動画を通して
一人でも多くの鳥類にこの僕の今感じて
いる気持ちと思いが届けばいいと思ってい
ます
[音楽]
あのクズを希望者読んであるので近いうち
にあなたの住処は撤去されると思うんです
けどももちこの動画を見ていたら自分から
退去することを切に願っております以上
です
[音楽]
ん